china has been trying to take an
apparently neutral stance so far but in
its media one side narrative is being
pushed over the other
here in beijing discussion of the
conflict is tightly controlled online
and offline
the only messages of support are hung
from friendly embassies like canadas
there are no protests against the war
not just because of china's
characteristic control but also because
people have a mixed view of the conflict
and who
[Music]
that's partly because they're getting a
very skewed version of the wall one
where the term invasion is banned
every day this giant screen in beijing
shows china's most important daily news
bulletin from state broadcaster cctv
it's almost like they're reporting a
different conflict you don't see any
sort of devastation when you do see it
on tv here it's a very sanitized version
you watch russians handing out foods to
ukrainian citizens you don't see the
cities that they have leveled this is a
big screen but china is not getting the
full picture
some experts have hoped that china might
play a positive mediating role given its
relationship with russia
what we can do
at this present situation
and it is very very limited
professor yin hong has previously
advised the chinese government it sounds
like you're saying china doesn't have
that much leverage china never in the
past as president and i believe in the
future and will support
russian military attack against the
ukraine
and we're supposed to russia's
you know adventurous
you know actions
and to
disturb
the european
uh security
as well as china will never support
an american sanctions against russia it
means that for all beijing's power and
economic might it has so far been
defined by inaction from the outside it
can look like indifference tom cheshire
sky news beijing